how long has it been since i last had to
talk about jk rowling
not long enough
so despite my hopes and intentions
here we are again and here we may be
again in the future i don't know
i've stopped telling myself you're done
now talking about this thing because
you know things just keep popping up
although this video is a little bit
different than the last few times i've
talked about ms rowling because
despite the timing and what you might
think this is not about her recently
released
thriller which features a serial killer
that is a man in a dress
that is sneaking into women's spaces in
order to kill them no i'm
not really interested in talking about
that it's been picked to death elsewhere
instead i want to talk about
how the actions of others and in some
cases the fan base
helped create the situation that we are
now in now i want to be very clear
i am not over the course of this video
no matter what you hear from me
absolving jk rowling of her views
or her actions up into this point
i am going to be talking about how other
factors
some of which people like myself
honestly had some degree of control or
at least impact on
contributed to everything but ultimately
at the end of the day
her beliefs are her beliefs they are not
because of someone else they are
the viewpoint she has chosen to embrace
and she has chosen to use her voice and
her platform to amplify those views
and that is on her no matter what that
ultimately is on her and also
i am not going to be debating the finer
points of
her specific beliefs it really
frustrates me when i try and have
broader conversations
and people try and bring up or get me to
try and debate and rebuke
every specific claim that she makes if
you want videos done that they've been
done by other people i'm not interested
in doing that
so going by the thumbnail
and the title i think there are two
major areas that i want to talk about
on how the actions of other people even
some people who consider themselves fans
of
harry potter if not jk rowling herself
contributed
to where we are right now with her
having really dug her heels in
and decided that this
view of transness that she has is not
only a hill she is prepared to die on
it's a hill she is prepared to
build hogwarts castle on top of
so one of these aspects is something
that i've heard talked about
elsewhere one of them i really haven't
so let's deal with the first one i have
seen it pointed out for example by
jessie jender and i'll link to her video
i swear she's not secretly
sponsoring these videos she's just a
friend and i really really like her work
but in a video where she brought up jk
rowling but she was mostly talking about
william shatner
and his sort of objection
to the use of the term cis and talked
about the response to that and how the
response from
people who were made uncomfortable by
what he was saying
has the potential to drive him and
people like him further and
deeper into
the problematic end
of transphobic beliefs without going
point for point but
trying to summarize what can happen
with someone who for whatever reason
either through a lack of information a
misunderstanding
not having in their own personal life a
point of reference for
transness who might be able to better
explain these things
when someone like william shatner jk
rowling
makes a public statement or in the case
of jk rowling's
timeline of transphobia
uh starts liking or following people who
espouse those ideas
there is a point at which people going
hey
don't do that can actually push those
folks deeper now this is not me saying
that you should not point out when
someone has done something that is
an issue but tone is important as is dog
piling
because you'll notice that the narrative
that often comes up and this came up
again
recently with gina carano and everything
that went on with
her twitter and her thing on pronouns
and again i don't want to break down
specifically what happened because the
specifics of what happened aren't what i
care about i want to have the broader
discussion
but she did this thing in her bio
related to pronouns that was
not taken particularly well it was
politely explained by some people
and she was attacked by others
and that can make someone i mean if
you're attacked you get defensive
that's just kind of what happens and so
when jk rowling started liking
tweets from transphobic creators or
started following
transphobic creators or influencers or
voices there were those
who probably just tried to point out hey
could you not you're making us nervous
and there were others who immediately
started tossing terms at her part of the
problem here
is honestly the way that we talk about
transphobia
and actually most um prejudices
because we have a tendency to talk about
it as if it's something that you
are and i really wish i don't know how
to do this
i really wish we could shift the
language in the conversation
to talk about transphobia as something
that you do
not something that you are so like for a
comparison
have you ever found yourself in a
situation with someone who you kind of
know but like aren't that close with
who's for whatever reason kind of being
a bit of a jerk
and you ever say to them hey you're kind
of being an apple right now
and they turn around and go did you just
call me and
you're like no i said you're behaving
like one
that's kind of like where i feel we are
with a lot of the transphobic
conversation somebody like jk rowling
does something that is transphobic
now committing a transphobic act or
making a transphobic statement
need not automatically may make that
person
themselves transphobic as some sort of
intrinsic thing about themselves that
will never change
but we still talk about it or lots of
people still talk about it as if
that's the case i think that's a big
part of the defensiveness
like think about like anything for
myself
if something that i have said or done is
point out like hey
that's a little misogynistic or that's a
little racist
part of me gets very defensive and
cleans up but i
i'm not misogynist i'm not racist and
the thing is they're talking about
something that i did
they're not necessarily saying that is
what i am
and i think if we could shift that
conversation we might
go a long way towards not
de-radicalizing the people who have
already swallowed the
kool-aid on this but keeping people
from getting pushed further down that
road
because when we talk about it like it's
well that means you are transphobic
then it's like we're throwing up our
hands and go you're already a lost cause
well what incentive do they have to
improve then
but if it's treated as something that
you did this
thing and it reflects it back on you in
this way
do you really is that what you really
want to have happen
maybe we could pull some people back
but there is that dog piling that
happens
and this again this is not me saying
that we should not
point out or push back on transphobic
actions or statements we
should but the way in which we do
matters and obviously
the kind of dog piling and accusation
and finger waving that i'm talking about
was not done by the majority of people
but it was done by enough of them
that it makes the people being addressed
people like jk rowling
feel that the entire community is coming
at them
which just reinforces the belief that
trans people dislike women
and are dangerous to them which was
where she was leaning and now has gone
all in on
so that's the first thing there's the
way that we talk about
and talk to people who have exhibited
transphobic actions
or statements that's part of the problem
and as i said i've heard that talked
about i mentioned jesse gender's video i
will link right there
but there's another element to this
over decades the
fandom prepped her to ignore
criticism
and let's be clear i don't think anybody
in the fandom could have known where
this was ultimately going to lead to
so it's not like we could have seen it
while we were in it but looking back on
it now
i look at the way the fandom rallied
around her
at earlier points well before any of
this
you look back when harry potter first
got big where did the big pushback come
from
well i can't speak for the uk but in
america at least
the big pushback came from
fundamentalist
christians who believed that it was
espousing
satanism that witchcraft
would somehow lead kids to worship satan
i don't know i can't follow the logic
but like that was a thing
and there were attempts and in some
municipalities or states
at least brief successes in getting the
book banned removed from libraries
keeping it out of the hands of kids
now all of these accusations were
absolutely ridiculous
and what did the fandom do we rallied
around ms rowling
and we said don't listen to them
they're wrong what you've done is
wonderful
don't listen to the hate and i'm not
saying that we were wrong for doing that
but that starts a pattern
that comes up again later because around
say uh let's go with
goblet of fires where it really started
becoming more evident some of the
inherently troublesome aspects and
implications
of the world that she's created there
are a couple but the tool that i'll
highlight briefly
there's the goblins and obviously the
goblins were introduced in the very
first book but they keep recurring
so this keeps getting reinforced the
goblins
they tread in a lot of anti-semitic
visuals and tropes and this may be
accidental
i'm not projecting intent on her but the
simple reality is
they bear a lot of hallmarks of
stereotypical anti-semitic
imagery large hook noses greed
every single goblin that we encounter
works at a bank
is a money changer is cunning
and you shouldn't trust them so there's
that
and then there's the house elves
demonstrably a slave race
a slave race that doesn't want to be
freed
because they're happier being slaves and
the one character who thinks that that's
wrong
gets continually at best
just tolerated like oh okay it's fine
that you think that
and at worst shut down by pretty much
every other character in the story
and she never really gets vindicated she
never really gets validated
that what is happening to the house
elves is wrong
and unfortunately that pit got dug a
little bit deeper
when we get to the fantastic beasts
films and
they tied house elves to
jazz culture in the 1920s
in america and jazz culture was
dominated especially at that point in
time
by black people so we have now just
much more directly made the comparison
of house elves
to black people and the history of
slavery there and yet you are continuing
to portray them as people who would
rather be slaves than be free
but when that would get pointed out
by some fans or sometimes people outside
the fandom
what did the majority of the fandom
including myself
do we said well you didn't mean it that
way
we don't think it's hateful you don't
have to listen
to that criticism
because we didn't want to taint
something that we loved
and in an effort to self-protect
something that we have put a lot of
emotional investment in we also
insulated the creator
we insulated the author
and so now we've begun a pattern
initially against the bizarre
fundamentalist religious issues with
harry potter
saying you don't have to listen to that
but then criticism started coming from
within the fandom
at the time when it first started
happening a minority of the fandom but
from within the fandom and what did we
say again
you don't have to listen to them
and so when she eventually published her
essay
laying out all of her beliefs
and everything that she thinks
trans people are that trans women are
men in dresses attempting to invade
female spaces and are dangerous
and that trans men are confused lesbians
who have somehow been brainwashed
is it all that surprising
that her reaction to pushback even from
within the fandom even from a
fairly significant portion of the fandom
is to go well i don't have to listen to
you
i don't have to listen to the hate
because that's what we've trained her to
do
through our coddling of her through our
handling of her with kid gloves through
our reassuring of her
she doesn't think she has to listen
no matter where the criticism's coming
from
and then that coupled with what i
mentioned earlier where some of the
criticism
was not
pleasantly directed and was done as
personal attacks
and was done in ways they could be
construed as threatening
you add those two together is it really
all that surprising
that she has just gone deeper and deeper
and deeper
into these beliefs again
i want to emphasize the fandom
and i count myself maya culpa
we contributed to where she landed
we bear some responsibility to this
but at the end these are her beliefs
that she has chosen to believe this does
not mean that she
gets to just go well it's not my fault
you people drove me to this no
no we did however clear a path
for her to walk she still chose to walk
it
but the fandom has some culpability in
this
and i think it's important and healthy
to recognize that
because it's part of my frustration in
addition to my general feelings about
the fact that you can't separate the
artist from the art see my earlier video
but in addition to that i think
that it's really unhealthy when i see
things like people saying
oh well she didn't write these books you
know
claiming that they either have no author
or
you know even in the sort of meme way
mentioning like oh well these other
people were like no
she wrote it and we
built it up and the way in which we
built it up
and built her up laid some of the
foundation
for where we now find ourselves and we
don't get to divorce ourselves from that
any more than she gets to divorce
herself from what she has been saying
and doing
these are things we should understand
and grapple with
and process
ultimately i kind of want to come back
to one of my initial points the idea of
separating
describing transphobia something that
you do instead of something that you are
because every now and then i get the
question or
the defense where someone either asks do
you think she's deeply transphobic in
her heart
or somebody arguing that they don't
believe that she is and ultimately
it doesn't matter very much to me
whether or not she
deeply holds these beliefs in her heart
or whether or not i think she does
because her actions the things that she
says
and putting them on a platform of her
size
are transphobic actions that cause
harm to a marginalized population
of trans people whether or not she is
transphobic
deeply wholly in her heart doesn't
matter and it does not reduce the damage
of what she is saying and what she is
doing
is jk rowling transphobic well
i made a video last year where i said
yes
these days i would probably not answer
it in that way my answer wouldn't really
change but i would say she is committing
transphobia
that is the thing that she is doing it's
also in theory a thing she could stop
doing
and while i don't have a realistic hope
that she will i
take some comfort in the knowledge that
addressing it in this way talking about
it as an action
instead of as a thing that you are
maybe people will understand that well i
can change what i do
and maybe more people will maybe not
who knows thank you very much for
listening
and if you've stuck all the way through
this an extra big thank you
i have a patreon which is actually how
i'm making my living and paying my bills
these days
and if you wish to contribute to what i
do i would greatly appreciate any
assistance you can lend
even if you're not able to do that
liking sharing subscribing and
commenting please
the comments on videos like this mean a
lot to me be respectful even if you
disagree with me
and also even if you agree with me i've
seen some people agreeing with me
getting
very uppity at other commenters don't do
that either
just no personal attacks please not me
not other commenters not even miss
rowling
let's talk about what's going on let's
not make it about demonizing
individuals because like i said at this
point that
tends to just drive the wedge a little
bit more but
please do leave your thoughts and let's
talk about it
now the main thing that i want you to
remember is
beautiful you are valid you are loved
and at the end of the day you are the
council
i am only running the meetings until
next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]